الى ولايه فلوريدا في الولايات المتحده
لمتابعه كلمه الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بعد مثوله امام المحكمه
وعدته من نيويورك ثم نواصل التغطيه
الديمقراطيون
حاولوا النيل مني هاجموني
ومن خلال
كثير من التحقيقات الزائفه روسيا روسيا
روسيا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا حاولوا
محاكمه بغرض العزل النيابيا مره ومرتين
وبعد ذلك فشلوا وانا ها هنا امامكم في
بي اي واوزاره العدل تسعياني لتحقيق
تغييرات تعديلات قانون غير قانونيه لقانون
الانتخابات
وحتى
الاصوات المزوره التي حشرت حشرا في صناديق
الاقتراض على مراه كاميرات المراقبه وايضا
يتحدث عن هنتر بايدن والممارسات الخاطئه
لعائله بايدن
وكل ذلك اثر في نتائج الانتخابات
في الحقيقه
16.9 هذا
النتيجه تكون
لمصلحتي لمصلحتنا جميعا لانها لمصلحه
البلدى
15 عندما قال وكيل المخابرات
معلومات مضلله وجدت في حاسوب هنتر بايدن
اكدت ذلك وقالوا انهم لم تكن معلومات
مضلله من روسيا
وطبعا امور تشبه ما يحدث في بلدان العالم
الثالث والتدخل في الانتخابات على نحو غير
معهود في بلادنا
وايضا ليقوم البن براجا اليوم المدع
العظيم الذي
انتخابات على اساس انه
سينال من الرئيس ترامب على هذا الاساس
خاضع الانتخابات قال انه سينال من الرئيس
ترامب باي ثمن قبل ان يعرف اي شيء عني كان
ياخذ حملته الانتخابيه على هذا الاساس وكل
من
نظره في هذه القضيه حتى الديم انه لا توجد
هناك جريمه وان هذه التهم ما كان يجب ان
ينبغي لها ان تقدم
[تصفيق]
قالوا هذا الامر لا ينبغي ان يحدث انه
اهانه لبلدنا لان العالم من الان يضحك
علينا بسبب امور اخرى مثل حاله حدودنا او
انسحابنا المخزن من افغانستان او بعد
خساره ما قيمته 85 مليار دولار من افضل
المعدات العسكريه وبعد من خسرنا الكثير من
حياه الشبابنا ومن خسروا اطرافهم
وبثرت اطرافهم اكثر
الفترات اثاره للخزي في تاريخنا حسب رايي
وايضا التخلي عن استقلاليتنا في مجال
الطاقه
واعتمادنا عليها لا نكثر من اي بلد اخر
طبعا
[موسيقى]
ايضا
الجريمه المرتفعه في المدن التي يديرها
الديمقراطيون وايضا
استخدام
الاسلحه بشكل لم يتم بحثه خارج اطار اداره
ترامب بحيث
يؤدي او تؤدي قياده بايدن للامور الى حدوث
حرب عالميه ثالثه تشنب السلاح النووي
من اكبر معدلات التضخم ومسلسل العسكريه
التي استخدمتها
لالحاق الهزيمه
بداعش في اربعه اسابيع
واستغرق غير اربعه سنوات وقتل البغدادي
والتخلص منه والتخلص من
معظم قادتهم حتى اثناء المراتب الان هم
يلجاون الى توجيه لائحه اتهام الى الرئيس
الرابع والخمسين للولايات المتحده
الذي حصل على 75 مليون صوت اكثر من اي
رئيس في منصبه في تاريخ الولاده المتحده
يعني حتى
المدعي العام في اطلانتا العنصري الذي
يحاول ادانتي بكل الطرق بما في ذلك
الاتصالات الهاتفيه
برئيس اوكرانيا
لا احد قال السيد ما ينبغي ان تفعل ذلك
لكن
لم يكن هناك شيء خطا قد قيل وفي النهايه
ما يتعلق بالتزوير الانتخابات في
جورجيا وغيرها ليس فقط انهم لم يعثروا على
اي شيء خطا في تلك المكالمات الهاتفيه
الان يتذكرون ان هناك مكالمات هاتفيه
اثرياتيه قضيه تثار فقط
للتدخل في انتخابات 2024
وسيتم التخلي عنها
[تصفيق]
اليسار الرازي الكاري
الذي
يلاحق ويضايق
المئات من انصاري كل يوم
يعرف الجميع
فيما يتعلق
بقانون
وثائق الرئاسيه والذي مررت قبل فتره طويله
وفقا لهذا القانون
انا ينبغي علي ان نتعامل مع قضايا ووثائق
الارشيف الوطني
وحتى هذا اليوم هناك مؤسسات او منظمات
يساريه
راديكاليه خطيره هذا ما تحتاج الى التعامل
معه لكن لا يوجد هناك ما يعتبر الجريمه
ارتكبتها انا في ظل قانون ارشيف الوطني
المتعلق بالوثائق الرئاسيه نحن كنا نتفاوض
بحسن نيه من اجل
اعاده الوثائق التي
جلبتها معي بشكل علني الى مارلاجو كما فعل
كل الرؤساء في الماضي
عندما
جاء محققون الاف بي اي ووزاره العدل انا
قلت لمحاميه
ان يبين لهم اين هي الغرف التي خزنت فيها
الوثائق وهم
اعقب ذلك الطرقات على الباب تستجبنا لها
بشكل فوري في وضع لم يخالف فيه القاده لكن
فجاه
اقتحم البيت
بالكثير من المحققين المسلحين اخذوا كل
شيء حتى الجواز سفري وكثير من الوثائق
يمكن ان تصدقوا ما حدث مثل هذا
هل سمعتم بالتعديل الرابع الذي يحمي الفرد
من مثل هذا الامور هم فعلوا ذلك رغم اننا
قلنا لهم ذلك
نظامنا القضائي اصبح بلا قانون ولم يفعلون
كل ذلك وغيره
للفوز في الانتخابات
ينظرون الي
ليس من هذا المنظور ولكن من منظور جديد
خرجوا به وهو من خلال
القانون
التجسس بالعام 1970 حيث العقوبه هي
الاعدام رغم ان ذلك لا علاقه له ابدا
باخذ صناديق بشكل علني تحتوي على وثائق
رسميه
وعمل ذلك كل اوباما وبرشلونه درايكن كل
عمل ذلك في الحقيقه
وهلر كلينتن تخلصت من 33 الف رساله بريد
الكتروني لم يسائلها احد عنها لكن
المحقق الخاص لا ادري اين هو الان
واخرون من امثال يقولون انه اسوا من
الاخرين
لانه
ينظر الى قضيه ترامب
ورغم رغم ان بايدن نقل صناديق من الوثائق
الى الى الى
حي الصيني انا استعدت مليارات من الصين
البعض من الوثائق اخذت الى مكاتب في
بنسلفانيا
حيث
خزنها وفي اماكن اخرى ايضا تم فيها تخزين
مثل هذا لكن هذا كله لا باس به لكن ما هو
مهم ان هناك
1850 صندوق في ضلعه والذي يرفض التخلي
عنها اليس هذا ما يتطلب
التفتيش بشانه
كرئيس انا لحق في رفع غطاء السريه عن عن
وثائق وليلحق ان ناخذها معي هذا من حقي
بايدن كان نائبا للرئيس
لم يكن لديه اي حق في رفع غطاء السريع عن
ايه وثائق ولا يخضع للقانون
الرئاسي الخاص بالوثائق الرئاسيه لكنه
يخضع لقوانين فيدراليه
غذائيه
فيها كان بحوزته وثائق سريه
وهو امر لا يمكن ان يعذر
وهناك اعضاء مجلس شيوخ من الديمقراطيه
العمل وبذلك لكن لم يتم اعتقال اي شخص
منهم مثل ما تعرض له الذين الاشخاص الذين
يعملون لدي
ورغم وجودي الاف والالاف من الوثائق
لانني كنت اعيق اذا سنبقى في متابعه تصور
كل ما جاء في حديث
الرئيس الامريكي السابق